Speaker 1: Let's hear from the most important
people in the audience and those are the viewers
and the listeners. We'll take some calls now from
our discord at David Pakman dot com slash discord,
starting with I hope I pronounce this
correctly. Rockman from Minneapolis,
welcome that I did. I pronounce that. Okay.
Speaker 2: Yes, you did. David, how are you doing?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Speaker 2: Good. Long time viewer. I've
been watching your shows since high school.
Speaker 1: Wow. Thank you.
Speaker 2: My question is, with everything
that's been going on the last two years,
do you believe that the Republican Party is trying
to reinstitute a 21st century version of Jim Crow?
Speaker 1: Well, most of them don't even know
what that is. So I would say not conscious. I
don't think they're using Jim Crow as a model. But
I do think that they are reacting with a lot of
the same instincts, where as they're increasingly
frustrated that the law doesn't allow them to do
certain things they want to do. They're trying
to find ways around it to achieve essentially
the same outcomes, if that makes sense. And that
includes when it comes to immigration policy,
this includes when it comes to educational
policy, you know, this idea of get rid of
the Department of Education, different things
like that. The impact of a lot of those things
would be similar to the impact of of some of the
things in place during the Jim Crow era. So in
that sense, I would say, yeah, to some degree.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Because when you when you look
back in the history books and you could see
the parallels with people going against the
LGBT community, going the water restriction. Yep,
the anti-abortion laws. When you look at Illinois,
what happened with Mary Miller and she is she
was ab she was saying this is a victory for white
life. Yep. That's that was coded language.
Speaker 1: I agree with you 100%. 100%. And
really, all we can do is try to ensure that
the people who want to do this stuff don't
get into positions of power. Sadly, many
of them are already in positions of power,
but at every opportunity to vote, let's try
to prevent more of them from being voted in.
Speaker 2: Okay. That was my only question.
Thanks for taking my call, David. All right.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Brockman from
Minneapolis, very much. Appreciate the call.